people in Russia and China are not
sitting around doing identity Politics
As I said at the time they're getting
ready and now you're starting to see the
Sergey lvov the Russian foreign minister
talked only days ago about how the
purpose of what they're doing in Ukraine
is to push America out of Eastern Europe
and it is to end the American global
dominance in the world that's what
people want and make no mistake about it
they're coming for what we have and I've
tried to make this point to people over
and over and over again we don't live in
some magical rainbow colored World in
which everyone wants to live happily and
and trade and whatever there are there
are a lot of people in the world who
just want what we have and they're
coming